you're one of the one of the only people
who dared boldly to try to formalize our
the idea of artificial general
intelligence to have a mathematical
framework for intelligence just like as
we mentioned termed
IHC AI X I so let me ask the basic
question what is IX e ok so let me first
say what it stands for because letter
stands for actually that's probably the
more basic question but it the first
question is usually how how it's
pronounced but finally I put it on the
website how it's pronounced and you
figured it out yeah the name comes from
AI artificial intelligence and the X I
is the Greek letter X I which are used
for solo manav's distribution for quite
stupid reasons which I'm not willing to
repeat here in front of camera so it
just happened to be more less arbitrary
I chose this I but it also has nice
other interpretations so their actions
and perceptions in this model around an
agent has actions and perceptions and
overtime so this is a Index IX index I
so this action at time I and then
followed by reception at time I will go
with that I lit out the first part yes
I'm just kidding I have some more
interpretations so at some point maybe
five years ago or ten years ago I
discovered in in Barcelona it wasn't a
big church there was in you know it's
stone engraved some text and the word I
see appeared there very surprised and
and and and happy about it and I looked
it up so it is Catalan language and it
means with some interpretation of dead
say that's the right thing to do yeah
Eureka oh so it's almost like destined
somehow came came to you in a dream so
Osceola there's a Chinese word I she
also written our galaxy if you
transcribe that opinion then the final
one is there is AI crossed with
interaction be
her status and it's going more to the
content now so good old-fashioned AI is
more about you know planning known the
domestic world and induction is more
about often you know iid data and
inferring models and essentially what
this is a model does is combining these
two and I actually also recently I think
heard that in Japanese AI means love so
so if you can combine excise somehow
with that I think we can there might be
some interesting ideas there so I let's
then take the next step can you maybe
talk at the big level of what is this
mathematical framework yeah so it
consists essentially of two parts one is
the learning and induction and
prediction part and the other one is the
planning part
so let's come first to the learning
induction prediction part which
essentially explained already before so
what we need for any agent to act well
is that it can somehow predict what
happens I mean if you have no idea what
your actions do how can you decide which
acts not good or not so you need to have
some model of what your actions affect
so what you do is you have some
experience you build models like
scientists you know of your experience
then you hope these models are roughly
correct and then you use these models
for prediction and the model is sorry to
interrupt
the model is based on your perception of
the world how your actions will affect
our world that's not so what is the
important part but it is technically
important but at this stage we can just
think about predicting say stock market
data weather data or IQ sequences one
two three four five what comes next yeah
so of course our actions affect what
we're doing what I come back to that in
a second so and I'll keep interrupting
so just to draw a line between
prediction and planning or what do you
mean by prediction in this in this way
it's trying to predict the the
environment without your long-term
action in the environment what is
prediction okay if you want to put the
actions in now okay then let's put in a
now yes so
another question ok so the simplest form
of prediction is that you just have data
which you passively observe and you want
to predict what happens without you know
interfering
as I said weather forecasting stock
market IQ sequences or just anything
okay and Salama of theory of induction
based on compression so you look for the
shortest program which describes your
data sequence and then you take this
program run it it reproduces your data
sequence by definition and then you let
it continue running and then it will
produce some predictions and you can
rigorously prove that for any prediction
task this is essentially the best
possible predictor of course if there's
a prediction task our task which is
unpredictable like you know your fair
coin flips yeah I cannot predict the
next reckon but Solomon of Tarsus says
ok next head is probably 50% it's the
best you can do so if something is
unpredictable so Lamar will also not
magically predict it but if there is
some pattern and predictability then
Solomonov induction we'll figure that
out eventually and not just eventually
but rather quickly and you can have
proof convergence rates whatever your
data is so there's pure magic in a sense
what's the catch well the catch is that
is not computable and we come back to
that later you cannot just implement it
in even this Google resources here and
run it and you know predict the stock
market and become rich I mean if ray
solomonoff already you know tried it at
the time but the basic task is you know
you're in the environment and you
interact with environment to try to
learn a model the environment and the
model is in the space as these all these
programs and your goal is to get a bunch
of programs that are simple and so let's
let's go to the actions now but actually
good that you asked usually I skip this
part also that is also a minor
contribution which I did so the action
part but they're usually sort of just
jump to the decision path so let me
explain to the action partner thanks for
asking so you have to modify it a little
bit by now not just predicting a
sequence which just comes to you but you
have an observation then you act somehow
and then you want to predict the next
observation
based on the past observation and your
action then you take the next action you
don't care about predicting it because
you're doing it and then you get the
next observation and you want more
before you get it you want to predict it
again based on your past
excellent observation sequence you just
condition extra on your actions there's
an interesting alternative that you also
try to predict your own actions if you
want oh in the past or the future what
are your future actions
wait let me wrap I think my brain is
broke we should maybe discuss that later
Biff after I've explained the aixi model
that's an interesting variation but
there's a really interesting variation
and a quick comment I don't know if you
want to insert that in here but you're
looking at in terms of observations
you're looking at the entire the big
history a long history of the
observations exact that's very important
the whole history from birth sort of of
the agent and we can come back to that
I'm also why this is important here
often you know in RL you have MVPs
Markov decision processes which are much
more limiting okay so now we can predict
conditioned on actions so even if the
influence environment but prediction is
not all we want to do right we also want
to act really in the world and the
question is how to choose the actions
and we don't want to greedily choose the
actions you know just you know what is
best in in the next time step and we
first I should say you know what is you
know how to be measure performance so we
measure performance by giving the agent
reward that's the so called
reinforcement learning framework so
every time step you can give it a
positive reward or negative reward or
baby no reward it could be a very scarce
right like if you play chess just at the
end of the game you give +1 for winning
or -1 for losing so in the aixi
framework that's completely sufficient
so occasionally you give a reward signal
and you ask the agent to maximize river
but not greedily sort of you know the
next one next one because that's very
bad in the long run if you're greedy so
but over the lifetime of the agent so
let's assume the agent lives for M times
that was there it dies in sort of
hundred years sharp that's just you know
the simples model to explain so it looks
at the future reward some
and ask what is my action sequence or
actually more precisely my policy which
leads in expectation because of the know
the world to the maximum reward some let
me give you an analogy in chess for
instance we know how to play optimally
in theory it's just a minimax strategy I
play the move which seems best to me
under the assumption that the opponent
plays the move which is best for him so
best so worst for me and the assumption
that he I play again the best move and
then you have this expecting max three
to the end of the game and then you back
propagate and then you get the best
possible move so that is the optimal
strategy which for norman already
figured out a long time ago for playing
adversarial games luckily or maybe
unluckily for the theory it becomes
harder the world is not always
adversarial so it can be if the other
humans in cooperative fear or nature is
usually I mean the dead nature is
stochastic you know you know things just
happen randomly or don't care about you
so what you have to take into account is
in noise yeah and not necessarily
doesn't really so you'll replace the
minimum on the opponent's side by an
expectation which is general enough to
include also adversarial cases so now
instead of a minimax trials you have an
expected max strategy so far so good so
that is well known it's called
sequential decision theory but the
question is on which probability
distribution do you base that if I have
the true probability distribution like
say I play backgammon right there's dice
and there's certain randomness involved
you know I can calculate probabilities
and feed it in the expecting max or the
signatures eg come up with the optimal
decision if I have enough compute but in
the before the real world we don't know
that you know what is the probability
you drive in front of me brakes and I
don't know you know so depends on all
kinds of things and especially new
situations I don't know so is it this
unknown thing about prediction and
there's where solomonov comes in so what
you do is in sequential decision jury it
just replace the true distribution which
we don't know by this Universal
distribution I didn't expect a talk
about it but this is used for universal
prediction and plug it into the
sequential decision mechanism and then
you get the best of both worlds you have
a long-term planning agent but it
doesn't need to know anything about the
world because the Solomon reduction part
learns can you explicitly try to
describe the universal distribution and
how some of induction plays a role here
yeah I'm trying to understand so what it
does it so in the simplest case I said
take the shortest program describing
your data run it have a prediction which
would be deterministic yes okay but you
should not just take a shortest program
but also consider the longer ones but
keep it lower a priori probability so in
the Bayesian framework you say our
priori any distribution which is a model
or stochastic program has a certain a
pre or probability which is two - two -
and why - ders - length you know I could
explain length of this program so longer
programs are punished yeah a priori and
then you multiplied with the so called
likelihood function yeah which is as the
name suggests is how likely is this
model given the data at hand so if you
have a very wrong model it's very
unlikely that this model is true so it
this very small number so even if the
model is simple it gets penalized by
that and what you do is then you take
just the sum word this is the average
over it and this gives you a probability
distribution so it was universal
distribution of Solomon of distribution
so it's weighed by the simplicity of the
program and likelihood yes it's kind of
a nice idea yeah so okay and then you
said there's you're playing N or M or
forgot the letter steps into the future
so how difficult is that problem what's
involved there okay so here's a cop to
mutation problem what do we do yeah so
you have a planning problem up to the
horizon M and that's exponential time in
in the horizon M which is I mean it's
computable but in fact intractable I
mean even for chess it's already
intractable to do that exactly and you
know it could be also discounted kind of
framework or so
so having a hard horizon you know at
number of years it's just for simplicity
of discussing the model and also
sometimes the mass is simple but there
are lots of variations actually quite
interesting parameter it's it's there's
nothing really problematic about it but
it's very interesting so for instance
you think no let's let's pin let's let
the parameter M tend to infinity right
you want an agent which lives forever
all right if you do it novel you have
two problems first the mathematics
breaks down because you have an infinite
revert sum which may give infinity and
getting river 0.1 in the time step is
infinity and giving you got one every
time service affinity so equally good
not really what we want another problem
is that if you have an infinite life you
can be lazy for as long as you want for
ten years yeah and then catch up with
the same expected reward and you know
think about yourself or you know or
maybe you know some friends or so if
they knew they lived forever you know
why work hard now or you know just enjoy
your life you know and then catch up
later so that's another problem with
infinite horizon and you mentioned yes
we can go to discounting but then the
standard discounting is so called
geometric discounting so $1 today is
about worth as much as you know one
dollar and five cents tomorrow so if you
do this local geometric discounting you
have introduced an effective horizon so
the agent is now motivated to look ahead
a certain amount of time effectively
it's likely moving horizon and for any
fixed effective horizon there is a
problem to solve which requires larger
horizon so if I look ahead you know five
time steps
I'm a terrible chess player right and I
need to look ahead longer if I play go I
probably have to look ahead even longer
so for every problem no forever horizon
there is a problem which this horizon
cannot solve yes but I introduced the
so-called near harmonic horizon which
goes down with one over T rather than
exponential in T which produces an agent
which effectively looks into the future
proportional to its age so if it's five
years old it plans for five years if
it's hundred years older than plans for
hundred years interesting and a little
bit similar to humans - right and my
children don't
I had very long within we get the doll
to a play I had more longer maybe when
we get all very old I mean we know that
we don't live forever and maybe then how
horizon shrinks again so just adjusting
the horizon what is there some
mathematical benefit of that of or is it
just a nice
I mean intuitively empirically we'll
probably a good idea to sort of push a
horizon back to uh extend the horizon as
you experience more of the world but is
there some mathematical conclusions here
that are beneficial mr. lamagno who
talks to the prediction party of
extremely strong finite time but no
finite data result so you have sown so
much data then you lose sown so much so
the dt r is really great with the aixi
model with the planning part many
results are only asymptotic which well
this is what is asymptotic means you can
prove for instance that in the long run
if the agent you know x long enough then
you know it performs optimal or some
nice things happens so but you don't
know how fast it converges yeah so it
may converge fast but we're just not
able to prove it because the typical
problem or maybe there's a bug in the in
the in the model so that is really dead
slow yeah so so that is what asymptotic
means sort of eventually but we don't
know how fast and if I give the agent a
fixed horizon M yeah then I cannot prove
our synthetic results right so I mean
sort of pivot dies in hundred years then
it number uses over cannot say
eventually so this is the advantage of
the discounting that I can prove our
synthetic results so just to clarify so
so I okay I made I've built up a model
well now in a moment I've have this way
of looking several steps ahead how do I
pick what action I will take it's like
with the playing chess right you do this
minimax in this case here do expect the
max based on the solo mode of
distribution you propagate back and then
while inaction falls out the action
which maximizes the future expected
reward on the Solano's distribution and
then you
take the section and then repeat that
you get a new observation and you feed
it in this extant observation then you
repeat and the reward so on yeah
so you rewrote - yeah and then maybe you
can even predict your own action I love
the idea but ok this big framework what
is it
this is I mean it's kind of a beautiful
mathematical framework to think about
artificial general intelligence what can
you what does it help you into it
about how to build such systems or maybe
from another perspective what does it
help us to in understanding AGI so when
I started in the field I was always
interested two things one was you know
AGI i'm the name didn't exist 10 2014
area wa strong AI and physics c or
everything so i switched back and forth
between computer science and physics
quite often
you said the theory of everything the
theory of everything just alike it was a
basic that regulators problems before
all all of humanity yeah I can explain
if you wanted some later time you know
why I'm interested in these two
questions Nestle and a small tangent if
if if one to be it was one to be solved
which one would you if one if you were
if an apple fell in your head and there
was a brilliant insight and you could
arrive at the solution to one would it
be a GI or the theory of everything
definitely a GI because once the a GI
problem solve they can ask the a GI to
solve the other problem for me yeah
brilliantly okay so so as you were
saying about it okay so and the reason
why I didn't settle I mean this thought
about you know once you have solved a GI
it solves all kinds of other not just as
your every problem but all kinds of use
more useful problems to humanity it's
very appealing to many people and you
know and it is thought also but I was
quite disappointed with the state of the
art of the field of AI there was some
theory you know about logical reasoning
but I was never convinced that this will
fly and
then there was this for more holistic
approaches with neural networks and I
didn't like these heuristics so and also
I didn't have any good idea myself so
that's the reason why I toggle back and
forth quite some violent even work so
four and a half years and a company
developing software something completely
unrelated but then I had this idea about
the ITC model and so what it gives you
it gives you a gold standard so I have
proven that this is the most intelligent
agents which anybody could build built
in quotation mark right because it's
just mathematical and you need infinite
compute yeah but this is the limit and
this is completely specified it's not
just a framework and it you know every
year tens of frameworks are developed
with just have skeletons and then pieces
are missing and usually this missing
pieces you know turn out to be really
really difficult and so this is
completely and uniquely defined and we
can analyze that mathematically and
we've also developed some approximations
I can talk about it a little bit later
that would dissolve the top-down
approach like say for Normans minimax
theory that's the theoretical optimal
play of games and now we need to
approximate it put heuristics in prune
the tree blah blah blah and so on so we
can do that also with a hike symbol but
for generally I it can also inspire
those and most of most researchers go
bottom-up right they have the systems
that try to make it more general more
intelligent it can inspire in which
direction to go what do you mean by that
so if you have some choice to make right
so how should they evaluate my system if
I can't do cross validation how should I
do my learning if my standard
regularization doesn't work well yeah so
the answers always this we have a system
which does everything that's actually
it's just you know completing the ivory
tower completely useless from a
practical point of view but you can look
at it and see oh yeah maybe you know I
can take some aspects and you know
instead of Kolmogorov complexity there
just take some compressors which has
been developed so far and for the
planning well we have used it here which
is also you know being used in go
and it I at least it's inspired me a lot
to have this formal definition and if
you look at other fields you know like I
always come back to physics because I'm
a physics background think about the
phenomena of energy that was a long time
a mysterious concept and at some point
it was completely formalized and that
really helped a lot and you can point
out a lot of these things which were
first mysterious and wake and then they
have been rigorously formalized speed
and acceleration has been confused tried
until it was formally defined here there
was a time like this and and people you
know often you know I don't have any
background you know still confuse it so
and this is a model or the the
intelligence definitions which is sort
of the dual to it we come back to that
later formalizes the notion of
intelligence uniquely and rigorously so
in in a sense it serves as kind of the
light at the end of the tunnel so yeah
so I mean there's a million questions I
could ask her so maybe the kind of okay
let's feel around in the dark a little
bit so there's been here a deep mind but
in general been a lot of breakthrough
ideas just like we've been saying around
reinforcement learning so how do you see
the progress in reinforcement learning
is different like which subset of IHC
does it occupy the current like you said
the maybe the Markov assumption is made
quite often in reinforce for learning
the there's this other assumptions made
in order to make the system work what do
you see is the difference connection
between reinforcement learning and I AXI
and so the major difference is that
essentially all other approaches they
make stronger assumptions so in
reinforcement learning the Markov
assumption is that the the next state or
next observation only depends on the on
the previous observation and not the
whole history which makes of course the
mathematics much easier rather than
dealing with histories of course their
profit from it also because then you
have algorithms which run on current
computers and do something practically
useful
for generally re all the assumptions
which are made by other approaches we
know already now they are limiting so
for instance usually you need a go
digital assumption in the MTP framework
in order to learn it goes this T
essentially means that you can recover
from your mistakes and that they are not
traps in the environment and if you make
this assumption then essentially you can
you know go back to a previous state go
there a couple of times and then learn
what what statistics and what the state
is like and then in the long run perform
well in this state yeah but there are no
fundamental problems but in real life we
know you know there can be one single
action you know one second of being
inattentive while driving a car fast you
know you can ruin the rest of my life I
can become quadriplegic or whatever so
and there's no recovery anymore so the
real world is not err gorica i always
say you know there are traps and there
are situations we are not recover from
and very little theory has been
developed for this case what about what
do you see in there in the context of I
see as the role of exploration sort of
you mentioned you know in the in the
real world and get into trouble and we
make the wrong decisions and really pay
for it but exploration is seems to be
fundamentally important for learning
about this world for gaining new
knowledge so is it his exploration baked
in another way to ask it what are the
parameters of this of IHC it can be
controlled yeah I say the good thing is
that there are no parameters to control
and some other people drag knobs to
control and you can do that I mean you
can modify axes so that you have some
knobs to play with if you want to but
the exploration is directly baked in and
that comes from the Bayesian learning
and the long-term planning so these
together already imply exploration you
can nicely and explicitly prove that for
a simple problem
like so-called bandit problems where you
say to give a real good example say you
have two medical treatments a and B you
don't know the effectiveness you try a a
little bit be a little bit but you don't
want to harm too many patients so you
have to sort of trade-off exploring yeah
and at some point you want to explore
and you can do the mathematics and
figure out the optimal strategy it took
a Bayesian agents they're also
non-bayesian agents but it shows that
this patient framework by taking a prior
over possible worlds doing the Bayesian
mixture than the Bayes optimal decision
with long term planning that is
important automatically implies
exploration also to the proper extent
not too much exploration and not too
little in this very simple settings in
the aixi model and was also able to
prove that it is a self optimizing
theorem or asymptotic optimality
theorems or later only asymptotic not
finite time bounds it seems like the
long term planning is a really important
but the long term part of the planet is
really important yes and also I mean
maybe a quick tangent how important do
you think is removing the Markov
assumption and looking at the full
history sort of intuitively of course
it's important but is it like
fundamentally transformative to the
entirety of the problem what's your
sense of it like because we all we make
that assumption quite often it's just
throwing away the past now I think it's
absolutely crucial the question is
whether there's a way to deal with it in
a more holistic and still sufficiently
well way so I have to come everything up
and fly but you know you have say some
you know key event in your life you know
a long time ago you know in some city or
something you realized you know that's a
really dangerous street or whatever
right here and you want to remember that
forever right in case you come back
they're kind of a selective kind of
memory so you remember that all the
important events in the past but somehow
selecting the importance is see that's
very hard yeah and I'm not concerned
about you know just storing the whole
history just you can calculate
you know human life says 30 or 100 years
doesn't matter right how much data comes
in through the vision system and the
auditory system you compress it a little
bit in this case La Salette and store it
we are soon in the means of just storing
it yeah but you still need to the
selection for the planning part and the
compression for the understanding part
the raw storage I'm really not concerned
about and I think we should just store
if you develop an agent
preferably just restore all the
interaction history and then you build
of course models on top of it and you
compress it and you are selective but
occasionally you go back to the old data
and reanalyze it based on your new
experience you have you know sometimes
you you're in school you learn all these
things you think it's totally useless
and you know much later you realize not
you know useless as you thought
you